we've talked a lot about the formations
of mountains and volcanoes when plates
are running into each other or one plate
is being subducted under another but
that isn't the only place it is the
dominant place or the most likely place
to find mountains or volcanoes on the
surface of the earth but that's not the
only place that mountains or volcanoes
can form and probably the biggest
example of volcanic activity or the most
popular one this might be a slightly
American Amero centric point of view but
the most often cited example of volcanic
activity away from a plate boundary is
Hawaii Hawaii so this right here these
are the Hawaiian Islands this is the Big
Island of Hawaii and it is it is
experiencing active an active volcano
lava is or magma was flowing from
underneath the ground and that once it
surfaces we call it lava and that lava
is actively making the island is
actively making the island bigger so
where is that volcanic activity coming
from and then how can we think about
that volcanic activity or that kind of
heat rising from below the surface of
the earth to explain some of the
geological features we see around Hawaii
so what we think is happening and once
again this is all theory right here is
that Hawaii is sitting on top of a hot
spot in particular the Big Island of
Hawaii is sitting on top of the hot spot
right now and this hot spot this hot
spot there's different ways different
theories on how it might emerge but we
think that at the mantle at the mantle
core boundary and I don't know in this
diagram whether they intended this white
area to be the core but let's just say
that this is the outer core down here
let's just say that this is the outer
core outer core for the sake of for the
sake of explaining things we they it's
possible that kind of plumes of very hot
material can kind of just based on kind
of the fluid dynamics of what's
happening at that mantle outer core
boundary that plumes of really hot
material can kind of rise up can kind of
let me do this in a darker color can
rise up from the outer core they would
rise up from the outer core and then
create hot
it's underneath the moving lithospheric
plates underneath the plates now it's
not necessarily don't know for sure
whether the hot spots are being created
from by these mantle plumes these this
material formed or heat it up at the
outer core mantle boundary but what we
do feel pretty confident about is that
there is this hot spot here and it's
independent of any of those convection
patterns that we saw
I shouldn't say independent it's
obviously all related because we have
all this fluidic motion going on in the
mantle but it's it's it's separate on
some degree from all of those convection
patterns that we talked about that would
actually cause the plates to move and to
a large degree or the way we think about
it right now this is stationary this
hotspot is stationary relative to the
plates and the reason why we feel pretty
good about thinking that it's stationary
relative to the plates is we see this
notion right here if you look at the
volcanic up if you look at the volcanic
rock in kawaiii which is one of the
older inhabited Hawaiian Islands the
oldest rock that we've observed there is
5.5 million years old and it's all
volcanic rock now the oldest rock we've
observed on the Big Island is about
seven hundred thousand years old
we also know we also know that the
Pacific plate you could look at this
diagram right over here is moving in
this general direction like we know it
from we know it from GPS measurements
it's moving exactly in the direction
that the hawaiian islands are kind of
distributed in so frankly the only good
explanation for why we see this pattern
well we see newer land here and then as
we go further and further up the
Hawaiian island chain we see older and
older land and actually if we keep going
if we keep going we have the leeward
islands over here and as we as we keep
measuring the rock on the leeward
islands they get older and older as you
go to the northwest and then if you even
look at what's below the ocean this is
the Big Island of Hawaii these are the
main Hawaiian Islands these are the
leeward islands but you see even beyond
that submersed
under the Pacific Ocean you continue to
see a chain of islands
so the explanation for what's happening
here is that you have a stationary
hotspot that is right now underneath the
Big Island of Hawaii and I'll just want
to be clear the Big Island is called the
Island of Hawaii it is one of the
islands in the state of Hawaii so I
don't want to cause you confusion I'll
just call it the Big Island from now
from from here on out so the hotspot is
right under the Big Island but if you
were to rewind five million years ago if
you were to rewind five million years
ago the entire Pacific plate the entire
Pacific plate was probably on the order
you know about 150 200 miles however far
kawaii is from the Big Island it was
probably shifted that much to the
southeast if you go back five million
years ago so five million years ago when
all of this was shifted down and to the
right then kawaii kawaii was on top of
the hotspot and so this is how each of
these islands are formed if you rewind a
ton of years then maybe this area over
here on the Pacific plate was over the
hotspot island an island formed there
then the Pacific plate kept moving to
the northwest it kept moving to the
northwest and new islands new volcanoes
kept forming those volcanoes would
release lava that would keep piling up
keep piling up heat piling up eventually
go above the surface of the water and
form this whole chain of islands and as
a whole Pacific plate kept moving to the
northwest
it kept forming new islands now the one
question you might ask is well how come
the Big Island is bigger is it has the
plate kind of paused over there is it
spending more time over the hotspot so
that more lava can kind of a form there
to form this to form this essentially
it's a it's an underwater mountain
that's now also above the water and
actually if you go from the base of the
Pacific Ocean
to the top of the Big Island of Hawaii
it's actually 50% higher than Mount ever
so you could really just view it as a
big mountain but the question is this
looks so much bigger than Kauai and they
keep getting smaller as you keep going
to the northwest is somehow the Pacific
plate slowing is it is it spending more
time here and the answer is it's
probably not slowing what's happening is
at one time Hawaii was also probably a
relatively large island if you rewind
five maybe five
five million years ago kawaii also might
have been about that big but over five
million years is just experienced a ton
of erosion remember once it moved over
the hot spot new land wasn't being
created it's in the middle of the
Pacific Ocean it's experiencing weather
five million years is a long period of
time and so it just got eroded over that
time so the older the island is the more
erode it's going to be and the smaller
it's going to be so if you go to these
if you go to these underwater mountains
up here that don't even surface above
the ocean at one time they might have
surfaced but over due to the ocean and
weather and whatnot
they've just been eroded over time to
become smaller and smaller kind of
remnants of volcanoes so anyway I
thought you would find that entertaining
of how the Hawaiian Islands actually got
formed and how we can actually have
these hotspots and these these this
volcanic activity and actually even
earthquake activity outside of actually
a plate boundaries actually while we're
looking at this diagram we talked about
we talked about the trenches that plate
boundaries you can actually see it here
went because this shows the depth and
the really dark dark dark dark blue is
really dark deep parts of the ocean so
this right here is the Mariana Trench
and you can see over here the Pacific
plate just getting abducted or she's not
abducted getting subducted into other
plates underneath and forms these
trenches here anyway hopefully you found
that entertaining